so they came up with this sixth Joe
Carter because of
for the Guinness
but it's 13 14 15 16 17 18.
so that's all there is is being taken
out of that
31 and made into a six
but what I dealt was I decided I would
do it with Apartments
oh
we'll we'll get to this as the class
guys but because we're head on we're
going to step each side of the line so
I'm going to step this side of the line
and the next movement we're both going
to set the other side of the line
and then we're going to go back to the
other side come into the middle
come back
so so I decided I'd do that the reason I
done it was so that we start to
understand the movement we understand
moving them so
stretch
then when it gets a bit more interesting
I decided let's make it five movements
and we've got the edge
so
we go
all right so
Edge Mini
so
she
maybe mix one Edge
then you miss one okay
and you miss me yeah
and then you eventually bring down the
line
foreign
youngsters or anybody young it is a
there you go a challenge
all right so we're going to do it from
the from the car to Quantum news after
all
I don't know
thank you
just want to look forward
don't do this to get you off stick
so down
stretch out it's very difficult it's
easier and don't do this on this
or else you're coming over here as you
go back here so
yeah
it's
um
[Music]
I'm quite it's quite important for me
that you don't just pick your gel up and
it's quite important when you don't pick
up like that the reason is psychosensory
he would shout and shout if you pick
that up with one hand it really shouts
me because he said if you're in a park
practice they knock it away from you you
haven't got a job
to defend yourself with them because it
is
to me Joe you're working with the job
you have to go to the job so two hands
on it very quick like so you everywhere
I go around the world you'll see people
do that because it's convenient
but they don't realize the space from
there to there
is
not Buddha
it's not protecting
so you come down here